what happens if something should happen
to him in those last six months it's
then too late to replace him I'm off the
grid for August but fear not CNN is
still a far left activist organization
pretending to be a journalistic outfit
Joe Biden's the weakest candidate Donald
Trump's the weakest candidate a majority
of their own party voters don't want
them to run and yet they lead their
respective primaries by so much and it's
one of the reasons why I'm unwilling to
say that Trump's the nominee even though
he's got a bigger lead than ever in
Republican party why do you think he's
might not be the nominee because there
is a weakness to him that the other
candidates have not figured out how to
exploit and that weakness is he promised
a lot but he delivered a little
how long is the Wall
47 50 miles and he said Mexico would pay
for it the last time I checked no money
came to him he promised to repeal
Obamacare did he
I don't want to take an argument of some
presidential candidate but he said he
was going to cut ways for Washington
spending the spending and the debt went
up higher the candidates haven't figured
out how to articulate that yet do you
think there are other Democrats out
there who
could be president former president
Trump no oh other democracy Cory Booker
could beat him Mitch Landrum could beat
him
um Gretchen Whitmer could beat him
but they're not going to get a chance
because Joe Biden doesn't want to step
aside and the thing that I say to people
watching right now who endorsed Joe
Biden what happens if something should
happen to him in those last six months
it's then too late to replace him that
we've never had a present this old we
never had a present in this condition
again I don't want to take sides I'm a
pollster but
these other candidates would be better
candidates against Donald Trump
so what is it you think stops the former
president Donald Trump from being the
Republican nominee by challenging the
fact that what he said is not what he
did it's not yelling at him it's not but
our sort of theoretical debates really
what is going to eat into the support
that the former president has the reason
why it's a smart decision for him not to
debate politically is because you can't
challenge him that way if he's not there